GINA: What up what up! I’m Gina.
BRITTANY: I’m Brittany.
DEWANDA: I’m DeWanda, and we’re the cast of Someone Great.
JEN: And I’m Jen, the writer/director of Someone Great.
ALL: This is the Best Friend Challenge!
GINA: Ooooh! What is the way to my heart, to mi corazón.
BRITTANY: Dogs! Food!  JEN: Tequila or dogs!
GINA: Joe!
JEN: I almost wrote Joe and then I was like dogs!
BRITTANY: Dogs!
GINA: You guys...humor, as well as acts of service.
DEWANDA: Ewwww!
GINA: I guess I was going real like, I dunno…
DEWANDA: I mean Joe, acts of service…
GINA: You’re right. He does—oh!
GINA: What!  JEN: What!
BRITTANY: Oh I don’t know—
DEWANDA: You said draw?
GINA: I don’t know how to draw it.
JEN: I’m just gonna write what it is ‘cause I—
GINA: Can I just—this is gonna be the worst picture of life.
BRITTANY: It’s a, it’s a finger point with a wink and an overbite and a kind of a hip movement.
JEN: Yes, I said uncomfortable wiggle!
GINA: Oh my god, so mine was like...a side to side—
DEWANDA: Yes! These are wig-arms!
DEWANDA: I love an emoji y’all.
GINA: I know.
DEWANDA: I have two because I’m diplomatic.
BRITTANY: Oh shoot! I did the poop and the laughing.
GINA: I did the laughing, or the crying with the tears going down.
DEWANDA: Crying! GINA: Yes crying!
DEWANDA: And body roll. Which is basically that.
GINA: Body roll. DEWANDA: Body roll.
BRITTANY: Uh, who would I want to?
GINA: Oooh, don’t steal my answer.
GINA: Michelle Williams.
DEWANDA: Why did we all choose such cold ass actresses—
JEN: This is not spelled right. I apologize Cate Blanchett.
BRITTANY: I almost put Amy Adams down, but then I thought like, they can’t be older than me because—
GINA: But who would you pick? BRITTANY: Oh.
JEN: No I’m thinking of like—
GINA: Who would you let play—
BRITTANY: More, yeah.
DEWANDA: Michelle Williams?
BRITTANY: Yeah.
ALL: Yeah!!!
JEN: Yes!
GINA: Oh, I know! I know which, what you are watching. C’mon. I know you know this.
BRITTANY: Herself. She’s watching herself.
GINA: Yeah!
DEWANDA: Yes!! That’s hilarious.
GINA: Um, that One Strange Rock, that Will Smith doc.
DEWANDA: ‘Cause Alano.
GINA: Yeah!
DEWANDA: Already watched that, presently watching Trigger Warning…
GINA: Killer Mike!
JEN: Killer Mike!
DEWANDA: And that new show with that bad bitch from Orange is the New Black. What is the name of that show.
GINA: Russian Doll!
DEWANDA/JEN: Russian Doll!!
BRITTANY: Oh.
GINA: Oh I know.
BRITTANY/GINA: Tina Fey!
DEWANDA: Yeah, I put...I wrote ‘Tiny Fey.’
ALL: DeWanda.
GINA: Yes! Bitch! Yes!
BRITTANY: Yes.
JEN: Yes!